james craig knows a lot about running
police departments he's run several he's
the most recently the police chief of
the city of detroit he's now running for
governor of michigan he joins us with a
reaction to these mandates and the
effect they're having in public safety
chief thanks so much for coming on so
what effect do you think these are going
to have on the public on people who want
to go to the grocery store without being
shot for example
you know i you know tucker first let me
start by saying how much i appreciate
you having me on your show but of course
it's just utterly ridiculous we're
talking about a mayor who wanted to
defund the police
so her wish is coming true in chicago
this is in effect defunding the police
it's reckless
and she does not speak for people who
live in vulnerable communities
whether it's there seattle and let's
talk about seattle the summer of love
that mayor
she wanted to defund the police they're
getting their wish
and they don't have any concept of how
to reduce violence in their city
uh it's reckless it's irresponsible
and
folks who are on the left who are
complicit who say nothing
they're as involved i'm just going to
say it is wrong well i think that i
think you're i think you're exactly
right if you take all the police away
and the murder rate spikes maybe you
stopped taking police away
i i have to ask you i mean you've doubt
you ran the policeman you've dealt with
unions where are the unions here i
thought the unions were supposed to be
strong i noticed they shake down
taxpayers why aren't they protecting
their own members honestly
well it depends on where you're talking
i i got to give
the
chicago union president a lot of credit
okay he stepped up his mayor referred to
him as a racist
uh the mayor and a judge referred to him
as being an insurrectionist
and that's wrong there's something
called
you know collective bargaining
collective bargaining
why don't you bring the union
and this city to the table and let's see
what we can do to work this out you know
these men and women men and women want
to do the job
but
when you do what
lori lightfoot did
that's not leadership
that's not leadership at all tucker and
i got to tell you
but this is all by design it's not by
accident so and then she pulls out the
race card and said what he's doing is
racist how is this racist
i mean really what's racist is the
people who live in vulnerable
communities
who are impacted by these bad decisions
about these reckless
mayors who need to just step down and
resign
i'm sorry you know and i got to tell you
tucker that's why i'm running for
governor
because i'm not going to sit back and
watch this that's why your viewers can
go to chief jamescraig.com
and say we want change this is about
leadership leading from the front
man you need change in that state state
the great state of michigan oh
absolutely i can go on all night
we have
chief great to see you tonight thank you
very much
thank you so much appreciate you tucker
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else